are you familiar with the word symbiosis
it's a fancy term for a partnership
between two different species such as
bees and flowers in a symbiosis both
species depend on each other I want to
tell you about a remarkable symbiosis
between a little bird the Clarks
Nutcracker
and a big tree the whitebark pine
whitebark grow in the mountains of
wyoming montana and other western states
they have huge canopies and lots of
needles which provide cover and shelter
for other plants and animals and
whitebark feed the forests the cones are
packed with protein squirrels gnaw the
cones from the upper branches so they
fall to the ground and then race down to
bury them in piles or mittens but they
don't get to keep all of them Grizzlies
and black bears love finding mittens but
there's more to a symbiosis than one
species feeding another in the case of
the Clarks Nutcracker this bird gives
back while gathering its seeds it also
replaced the trees here's how it works
using her powerful beak a nutcracker
picks apart a cone in a treetop pulling
out the seeds she can store up to 80 of
them in a pouch in her throat then she
flies through the forest looking for a
place to cash the seeds an inch under
the soil piles of up to eight seeds
nutcrackers can gather up to 90,000
seeds in the autumn which they return
for in the winter and spring and these
birds are smart they remember where all
those seeds are they even use landmarks
on the landscape trees stumps rocks to
triangulate to cache is buried deep
under the snow what they don't go back
and get those seeds become whitebark
this symbiosis is so important to both
species that they've changed or evolved
to suit each other
nutcrackers had developed long tough
beaks for extracting seeds from cones
and white barks branches all sweep
upwards with the cones at the very ends
so they can offer them to the
nutcrackers as they fly by
that's a symbiosis two species
cooperating to help each other for the
benefit of all
you